okay so our next talk will be by W Raja
about by unitary constructions in
quantum information a quantum story yeah
thanks for your introduction yeah
I'm David Reuter I'm a PhD student at
Oxford and I'm about to present joint
work with my supervisor Jamie Vickery on
by unitary constructions in quantum
information and as this title sounds a
bit technical I decided to call it by
unitary constructions in front of
information a quantum story and I
descended in the form of a little story
every story needs protagonists and in
part one of this talk quantum structures
we meet these protagonists and we end
the part with a long list of formulas
that's what we like about part about
talks not really that's why does part
two of this talk Shadid tensor networks
I'm going to introduce these colorful
pictures and they are going to replace
the formulas of part one and really you
can think of this talk as a as an
advertisement for this shader tensor
networks and they do some quantum
information theory so what are our
protagonists our protagonists are
quantum structures an example for
quantum structure is a had a map matrix
Adamek matrix is the square complex
matrix such that every entry has modulus
one and such that matrix is proportional
to a unitary matrix the harder my matrix
we all love and know is the following 1
1 1 minus 1 it's clearly that this is
the hedonic matrix you just every entry
as modulus 1 is proportional to unitary
matrix but there are many many more
interesting complicated weird hirama
matrices around the other protagonists
of this talk are unitary era bases a
unitary era basis is a collection of
unitary matrices that are orthogonal
with respect to each other under the
trace in a product so unitary era basis
is like an orthonormal basis for the
space of matrices consisting entirely of
you
matrices and the most important unit
area basis in quantum information theory
is clearly the following which is the
poly matrices and so you know torero
bases generalize the poly matrices so
why are these quantities our
protagonists why should we care about
them what's interesting about them well
let's start with Hatami matrices how do
my matrices correspond to mutually
unbiased bases and mutually unbiased
spaces are everywhere on quantum
information theory many important
protocols an example here is quantum key
distribution are built basically on this
idea of mutually unbiasness so this is
the central concept in quantum
information theory unitary era basis
were first developed as a generalization
of the Pauli matrices in the theory of
quantum error correction but they have
many other applications so one good
example I guess is unitary bases
classified quantum teleportation
protocols and they also classify Ben's
coding schemes
so again unitary era bases pop up
everywhere in quantum information theory
I would even go as far as saying that as
soon as we have a quantum protocol which
is somehow built on entanglement then
it's quite likely that at a mathematical
heart of this protocol there's one of
these quantum structures so there's
definitely enough incentive to
understand these quantum structures to
understand the space of all these
quantum structures to understand how
these quantum structures interact with
each other
to understand how why they can really
get how crazy and how different from
these examples I've been showing here in
the last slide they are or just simply
to classify them but that's a really
hard task they are actually known to be
really really hard to classify how do my
matrices are classified upto dimension 5
and they've been around for quite some
time the general structure of unitary
era basis is virtually unknown you just
have no idea in dimension two they're
all equivalent to poly matrices but in
dimension 3 or higher anything goes
nevertheless there are several known
constructions of unit area basis and
hirama matrices so just to do some
name-dropping here probably the
best-known constructions which give an
example of what I'm going to talk about
is its Thetis construction from 2004
which is a construction of hirama
matrices or burners quite famous shift a
multi-player construction from 2001 for
unitary era bases all these
constructions have like a common ground
a basic common idea and this idea is
that you use quantum structures and take
them together to obtain new quantum
structures of higher dimensions so what
do I mean with this let me let me just
give an explicit example coming to our
slide for the formulas let's think about
constructing hirama matrices we can take
for example two Hatami matrices a and B
and just take the tensor product the
index expression is written here the
resulting thing is again a Hottentot
matrix you can pretty much see that
every engine has modulus one and you can
easily check that the corresponding
matrix is unitary so that's all simple
and clear we can slightly generalize
this formula as follows if a write B
superscript C I mean it's a list of
fátima matrices so B superscript 1 is a
harder my matrix B superscript 2 is
harder map matrix B superscript 3 years
ahead I'm a matrix so really this tensor
be CBD is really a list of hirama
matrices and if I take them together in
this way the resulting thing is again a
harem a matrix that every entry as
modulus 1 is again full straightforward
and easily to be seen here that it's
unitary not that obvious to me just from
the formula but obviously you can just
write down unitarity equation and check
that it holds
similar similar equations similar
formulas hold for the construction of
unitary error basis the best example of
where now an example is to following
where we just take a harem a matrix a
and from this we can construct a unit
Riera basis as given in this formula
this construction can be generalized to
the following here we take three
different Hatami matrices a B and C and
basically apply the same formula and we
again get a unitary error basis but we
can write down different constructions
like the following here we take a family
of fátima matrices a superscript b and
two unitary arab basis and construct a
unitary error basis of higher dimension
well let's go even more crazy and write
down the following formula where we take
for harder my matrices and the unitary
error basis to construct a generator our
bases in quite a high dimension for this
last construction I invite all of you if
you're very motivated and maybe a bit
bored to really prove that this actually
defines a unitary basis to prove that
this formula is unitary and that the
different you ABCs are actually
orthogonal with respect to each other
and I tell you it's not easy to show
that it's it's a straightforward
calculation but it will take some time
and there are more formulas of that form
but so not the question of proving these
equations is interesting but really more
like whether these equations come from
why do they work how can we come up with
them right I've just written down a list
of index expressions and told you yeah
you know you can check it so you share a
basis but really why am I doing this
like how how does how do you come up
with these constructions do we just sit
down and write down index expressions in
a long list and just some of them might
work others might not work so far it's
really has been basically ad hoc
calculation and I'm going to present you
a way to think of these equations and to
think of these structures but basically
lets you come up with all these
constructions and a very nice and simple
way and that helps you kind of
understand the space of these these
quantities so yeah the main question
here is what's going on
so let me give two more comments about
this slide before I move on firstly
should be noted that only the first
three constructions on this slide have
actually previously been known all other
constructions on this slide are new and
secondly the constructions are logically
independent so I'm not cheating you're
here and just take but I haven't just
taken one construction and iterated it
20 times we've written it out and in a
weird form so these constructions don't
imply it are there they are not there
like logically independent from each
other right so that's our mystery where
do these constructions come from how do
these structures behave with respect to
each other and to understand this
mystery we have to go step back and go
into new territory to understand what's
going on and that leads me to part two
of my talk and this part two is about a
new setting and this new setting explain
algebras in 1999 born Shone's famous for
his jones polynomial introduced the
theory of planar algebras and planer
algebras in a very very rough sense is
about diagrams like the following is
like nice colorful diagrams plain
address have many names for example they
are basically equivalent to higher
category theory that's the direction I
come from but there are also a special
case of plane algebras our tensor
networks and we all have heard of tensor
networks today in the other days then
address have many many applications and
mathematics they are very important for
the classification of sub vectors and
operator algebras or for the
classification of fusion categories in
physics they're used in statistical
mechanics in topological quantum field
theory in string theory in condensed
matter theory well then I'm suggesting
we should also use them in quantum
information theory why am i why am I
suggesting this most what is the basic
idea here there's a concept which was
invented by Jones actually in his
original planar algebra paper called by
unitarity and I propose that we can use
this concept to solve our mystery of
these quantum constructions or at least
to better understand this myth
I mean solving is a strong word so
what's going on what's the planer about
what am I talking about here to
understand what planer algebras are or
how we can use plain address as quantum
information lists let's go back to talk
about tensor networks tensor networks
after following traffic components we
have vector spaces which are represented
by wires with the vertices represent
linear maps so proof comment here is
that time runs from bottom to top for me
so linear map from V to W is depicted as
shown here and vertices with many lakhs
basically correspond to linear maps
between tensor products of vector spaces
now we can put these components together
in a tensor network like the following
and such a tensor network such a
contraction of linear maps just
corresponds to a composer in air map in
this case a composed linear map from the
vector space a tensor F to a and here on
the Left I've written a little legend to
kind of subtract we can see what's
actually going on right so that's
suppose we have two following situation
we don't just want to talk about 1
tensor network we really want to talk
about a family of tensor networks so
let's suppose we in the following
situation here all these tensor networks
this is a family of tensor networks
labeled by I and J they are all of the
same form but it involves different
vector spaces and different linear Maps
so really if I vary over I and J I just
get bunch of tensor networks and I could
write them down in a list if you want it
will look the same but if different
ingredients is so let's suppose we want
to argue about these kind of these
structures these structures as family of
tensor networks
I will now introduce a graphically
component to this calculus to the
calculus of tensor network I would
extend it so that we are able to talk
about these families of linear maps in a
unified and is simplified in one picture
basically so I'm going to draw pictures
like the following on the Left I again
have a little legend - and I go I talk
you through it
what every component here means the
shaded regions really correspond to
indexing sense so the blue region
corresponds to mimics I the red region
corresponds to an index J wires between
two regions correspond to family
affected spaces labeled by the adjacent
regions so here this wire on the bottom
between the blue and the red region it's
the family of vector spaces labeled by I
on the left and Shea on the RUS right
the wire on the bottom right the wire
which which is labeled by FJ labels the
family of vector spaces labeled by the
adjacent region labeled by J and the
same is true for vertices vertices
correspond now to family of linear maps
labeled by all adjacent regions so over
all such a graphical picture really
corresponds to this family of tensor
networks so I have this family of tensor
networks and I can turn it into this
picture and if you see this picture you
know how to translate it back into this
family of tensile networks right so I'm
the thing I'm I'm proposing here or I'm
introducing is this notation where we
can say these two dimensional pictures
with shaded regions correspond to
families of tensile networks and the
other way around so we can go both ways
so in some sense you can think of this
religious as a slick nice or not so nice
whatever you prefer notation and as
always with notations we have to show
that these notations actually make sense
that they are useful but they're not
complicating what we're doing but they
are simplifying and that's basically the
point of this talk here I want to show
that using this notation we can get
across on a certain kind of structural
behavior in quantum information theory
which we otherwise probably wouldn't
have done so now that we've introduced
these these shader tensor networks we
can also think about specific tensors in
these shader tenser networks and I want
to consider a very simple kind if you
want a very simple kind of equation a
tensor that's by unitary so by unitary
for me it's a full valent tensor it's a
tensor like the following with four legs
that fulfills these two equations or
these four equations the first equation
set is its unitarity for those of you
have some experience with tensor
networks it's basically the same
unitarity equation we know we take the
tensor composed with its adjoint and
it's it's it's the identity of the
specific type and the other way around
as well I've purposefully witnessed as
vertical unitarity because there's a
sense of going from bottom to top but
since we're drawing two-dimensional
pictures here we could also ask for
horizontal unitarity so if you just turn
around our head it becomes to say in
vertical unitarity equation just as in a
horizontal way so to note here is that
it's only horizontal unitary up to a
scalar but that scalar is not too
important it's similar to the situation
with Hatami matrices where every entry
has modulus 1 but the matrix is only
proportional to a unitary right so what
do these by unitary by unitarity
equations really mean what are they
about
what we can translate it back into
families of tensor networks than this
you really corresponds to a family of
linear maps labeled by red blue and
green and yellow label by red blue green
and yellow region and this family of
tens and networks
fulfills certain equations for certain
algebraic equations right and if you
introduce h break equation
we have to ask what are they good for
what are they talking about Anna brings
me to a surprising connection these
algebraic did I tried equations despite
your neutrality equations they
correspond precisely to the equations
defining our quantum structures actually
back in 1999 in his original vena
algebra paper Jones noted that hirama
matrices are by unit Riis of the
following type so this is again just a
family of tensor networks in this
graphical calculus I have to specify
certain regions and certain wires and
then the equations which tell me that
this tensor is about eulogy exactly
correspond to saying that the
corresponding family of tensor networks
is a harimao matrix so how do my
matrices I want one correspondence with
by unities of this form the data for
hada my matrix is precisely determined
by being a by unitary of that form so
now by unitarity is is asking about
vertical unitarity in horizontal
unitarity so the notion is inherently
symmetric under basically tilting our
head by 90 degrees right so if you have
four by unity until divided by 90
degrees it's definitely again a by
unitary so really if you tilt our head
if you look at this picture and hit our
head by 90 degrees we see the following
picture so these while unities are also
had a mummy Tracy's oh that's a certain
symmetry in there in the constructional
I'm describing him so those are had
other matrices in 2012 Vickery showed
that unitary our bases are also by
energies but this time of the following
type so the difference between Hatami
matrices military bases you can think of
it as just a different type but it's the
same equation it's the same by unitarity
equation how do my matrices if you want
left-right shaded by geometries
generally our bases are only shaded on
the Left hsf normal vector spaces as Y
as are no families effective spaces
there
another important by unitary which I'm
going to need for my construction I
first of all we can obviously again tilt
our head by 90 degrees and these things
also correspond to few DS so the last
component I'm going to need for my
constructions and that looks a bit more
complicated as families of Hadden are
matrices so family life as a family of
had my major agencies
I again mean the lists of hirama
matrices I've been describing in the
second slide these index lists a family
of fátima matrices corresponds to a by
unitary of the following type so here
this picture three dimensional so I have
to prove region and areal and a yellow
region in front the different colors are
not really important so there's no
mathematical mathematically like reason
why I use different colors it's just
easier to read the three dimensionality
from the picture here so you can think
of this type is basically being the type
of hirama matrix but with an additional
half plane sheet with an additional
yellow half plane sheet attached and I
can attach the sheet along any direction
video I want and I can also attach it to
the rear or the front of the Hatami
matrix so that doesn't make a difference
so these are our basic quantum
structures and they correspond precisely
to by unitary so if you want to by
unitarity equation we have seen unifies
these quantum structures so what can we
do with these things why are they why
are they useful why is this a useful
perspective so suppose we have two
generic channel by unit of this form
then we can join them or contract them
together along a diagonal like this that
obviously only works if two types
if the types match and the result is
again about unitary but why is that true
if you have some experience with tensor
networks you pretty much see that this
is again unitary it's just a I mean you
just compose it with its adjoint and it
all works out but then if you teach
ahead by 90 degrees
the picture looks pretty much the same
so it's also horizontal energy so given
to each by unitary 's we can compose
them diagonally to obtain another by
unitary
we can also compose some olimpiadas
diagonal obviously today's no good
chosen the Agner so what do we know now
we know that quantum structures are by
unit Aries and we know that we can
compose by unit Aries so the logical
next step for us is to compose quantum
structures and I'm going to do that now
so here on the top of the frame I've
shown the types of my energies we are
interested in how to my matrices ginger
area basis and families of fátima
matrices and I'm going to show you the
following construction so what happens
here is a is a family of hirama matrices
grad you can compared with the picture
on the top right is exactly the same B
is the Gann a family of had AMA matrices
this time to half shade the half plane
she is just a touch along a different
diagonal so what's the reciting overall
type the reciting overall type is a
picture with two shaded wings it has a
shaded left wing and a shaded right wing
the wing is basically yellow in front of
blue but we can think of this just as a
sandwich collar it's just a new color
yellowish blue purple maybe it s is this
is similar to intense the network's if
we have two vector spaces we can either
think of it as two wires next to each
other or we think of it as a fake new
wire if you want so the overall type of
this thing is the type of a Hatami
matrix so what we have done is we've
taken a controlled family of hardened
homages a controlled family of fátima
matrices sort of them is Bayona trees
compose them together the result will
have the overall type of Hatami matrix
and we know it's about unitary but
facilities of this type
Haddam are matrices so what happens is
that we have written down a construction
for hirama matrix from true controlled
families of hirama matrices and we can
actually write down the iMix expression
for this construction if we again use
this translation into families of
tensile networks and that's the
following expression we've seen on slide
so let me give another construction here
we take a Hanauma matrix B another
Hatami matrix C and a third had a my
matrix a and overall type of this thing
if you again compare it with the first
row of pictures is a unitary error basis
so what we've done here is we've
constructed a unit area basis and the
corresponding formula if you again
translate these pictures into into
tensors tensor expressions is the
following and we can go on like this for
example we can look at the constructions
like this so it's not important here
that you really it's really clear how
these are composed together there's a
bit tricky but in principle it's again
the same idea that we take my geometries
and compose them diagonally with each
other
here we I've introduced another boy's
unitary which are quantum Latin squares
from a quantum Latin square is the
square grid of vectors such at each row
and each column is an orthonormal basis
so this is also quantum structure that's
by geometry of a different type and we
can use them in these constructions to
kind of enrich our space of
constructions but it's not really
important you could also drop them but
then you just have less constructions
and those are just families of
constructions we can make so those are
all constructions that work and you can
basically play this game just write down
a huge lattice of Bayona trees compose
them together and all kind of weird ways
and it's their works and we would say
give you in this case geometry our bases
we've also used the construction here on
the bottom left to actually construct an
actual unit area basis so we've chosen
how to my matrices and just written down
a unit area basis and eight times a
general error' basis and we've proven
the description that this unit of air
bases cannot be obtained from any of the
previously known construction so that
really gives us new structures new
quantum structures right so
what have you done in the actual paper
we have classified quantum structures in
terms of by unitary engineer the tensor
networks so we've unified this notion of
quantum structure we've then compose
them
by doing this we've obtained a simple
graphic of calculus to come up with many
new constructions involving Hatami
matrices unit area basis in quantum
Latin squares so you can really think of
the strategy of calculus as some kind of
Lego you really have these basic
building blocks you clue them together
in all kinds of funny ways and a result
if the type is right so cystic matter of
type checking if the resulting type is
the correct one you know that you'll get
a construction which gives you a new
general basis and we have shown that
these constructions actually give rise
to news you nurture a basis which cannot
be obtained from any of the previously
known methods so hope you've been
excited into shape tensor networks and
you've seen that they might really be
useful and there might be a useful
extension of the theory of tensor
networks if you want to know the full
story or if you want to see a four-page
long list of 64 8 times 8 matrices
that's actually initially our basis
we've constructed but you can also skip
over it then have a look at our paper
and since I still have some minutes left
I would briefly like to comment on how
these fish oils might play a role in a
classification of janeshia era bases so
what we've seen is we basically now have
this scheme for constructing new
examples of Uri bees and these new
examples are far more exotic than the
examples that have previously been known
so to prove in our case in our paper
that the new Juby we've constructed is
actually more general than the ones that
could have been constructed from earlier
constructors we've basically used as
exoticness we've used that this year B
doesn't fulfill certain niceness
properties if you want also something we
take away from this is that we expect
more examples of you B's and composite
dimensions because many of the
constructions we've presented here
actually gives you a B's in composite
dimensions and that's very similar to
the case of Hatami matrices
since we're now today because some of
the harder mark constructions were
already previously known that there are
more other matrices and composite
dimensions it's not the coincidence of
hirama matrices have only been
classified upto dimension 5 and then in
dimension 6 we have 3 times 2 and they
are complicated three-dimensional how
that my matrices so if no idea what's
going on in dimension
six so our research also suggests from
what I've been saying that we should
probably consider Yui B's in the larger
context of all my energies so we
shouldn't consider Julie B's as
something and harder map matrices or
something else we should consider them
as one big concept and like special
cases of one in the same larger concept
and yes so that's it from me and I hope
you enjoyed the talk and I thank you for
your attention and if you have any
question questions
well I'll start with a question which is
probably a very naive one you started
with a mapping between planar diagrams
and tensor networks but it seemed that
in your constructions you departed from
this plane our right structure so - so
is the actual class of diagrams that
you're working with some kind of broader
class yes it's not so the name planer is
probably misleading because the people
who invented these planar diagrams
actually wanted to consider them as
planar diagrams but you can consider non
planar diagrams and that that's what we
do so we have really three dimensional
diagrams here but that's alright because
if you look at the actual translation
which is here there is nothing which
prevents you from using non planar
diagrams here it's still like the
translations they go through there's
nothing telling you you know this has to
be planar yeah
so you have introduced three or four
different types of by unit Ares yeah
based on the different kinds of
colorings that you can have are there
other kinds of by unit Ares you can get
by fiddling around with which colors you
make and are any of those known
structures already and sub-question are
there any that aren't known structures
that could be interesting things to look
at
yes it just suggested by this yeah so we
have these structures then as I said we
have this quantum Latin squares that
also correspond to by unit race but then
you could use that you could basically
write down different types and these
types still lead to constructions of
geometry our bases and these correspond
to weird unitary like structures we have
matrices with block form which have some
properties and we can actually write
them down and that's something we've
we've been looking at and we might fit
that into a paper so you can actually
write our new quantum structures which
gives you which you can also use for URI
B's but definitely the simplest the
simplest and kind of easiest to
understand structures here I really have
about matrices gops and these quantum
Latin squares but yes that's but yeah
you can definitely look at more
complicated by energies and we probably
should at some point other question yeah
there's one in the birthday so you said
that you gave a classification but what
was the equivalence relation right so I
definitely didn't give a classification
of you B's that's like a really open
heart problem there is an equivalence
relation of what to which which
classification that you mean well dance
you have a slide that you classified all
these could you could you get the last
slide if that's possible
Crosswhite quantum structures in title
one or three in shape right right right
that's not the coolest relation in the
site right so here it's not it's not
classified in the sense of their student
doesn't need to be an equivalence
relation so here it's really if you just
write down the by unitarity equation
that just gives you an intense
expression this tense expressions just
saying it's out of my matrix so
absolutely quality if you want there's
no equivalence relations right my second
question is that imagine I give you a PI
entry with like with many input and
output legs mm-hmm do you have a way of
decomposing it into yeah my entries or
yes
that's a good question no there's no
obvious way to do it
there definitely so for for these
constructions if you pick a specific
construction then if you say compose to
harder my matrices or 300 matrices to
get a new beat and this UV has certain
properties which you can check or at
least can see you know that definitely
doesn't arise from such decomposition
but these kind of questions are exactly
what is going to be important in a
classification of ueb is to say you know
if I have a newbie is it is it of this
composed type is it a generic u.e.b
which doesn't arise from a composition
so this is exactly the important kind of
questions we have to ask here but I
don't expect to there's like a graphical
answer to it as probably really depends
on the specific cases you consider and
it will be like hard linear algebra
other questions
so you do these constructions by
constructing these diagrams but do you
have a systematic way of actually
enumerated all of the useful diagrams
yes in the paper we have a list of all
compositions we can write down which
only use two or three by unit Ares so so
actually the first two constructions
here they look a bit weird and that's
because they are in this list so those
are actually like the most general
things we can we can do with three by
unit Ares but we have stopped after
three because then it gets pretty hard
and they're pretty they are quite a lot
of solutions there but you could in
principle work out the way you can
basically just take two Bayona trees as
soon as they fit together you can post
them together and you'll just see
whether you get the type of UAB out of
it so in principle it works it's there
it's probably some nicer Uyghur in there
than just this enumerator that we've
tried but yes that's that's also an
important question now other questions
all right well let's thank David again
you